Returning to the previous safe_insert example, let's demonstrate how to
use new techniques making the operation safe_insert actually safe.
Just like in the threads creation code we have threads T0 and
T1 and they both want to perform the safe_insert operation.
The parent thread T0 wants to perform safe_insert with an element 6, and
the child thread wants to perform safe_insert with a value of 4.
Let's assume that once the parent created the child T1
it continued executing and was the first one to reach safe_insert with value 6.
It will acquire the log and start inserting the element 6 on the list.
What that means, T0 has the log and when T1, the child,
reaches the safe_insert operation it will try to acquire the lock as well and
it will not be successful it will be blocked.
At some later point, T0 will release the lock, T1 will acquire the lock, and
then T1 will be able to insert its element onto the front of the list.
So in this case, the final ordering of the list will be 4 followed by 6.
Since we're always inserting in the front of the list.
That's how we describe this operation.
So, the parent inserted its element first, and
then the child thread was the second one to insert the value 4 into the list.